a story you'll only see on Aid a family
searching for a missing cross at the
memorial site of their son their son
passed away 12 years ago and they placed
across at the site near Craig and
Cimarron Matt
a spoke to the family who wants it
returned
to live every day without him here it's
just unreal and unhar you know and then
just to come here and see that the cross
has gone gone
it's just
that makes it even brings everything
back to the surface we see them all
across the valley memorials set up for
lost to loved ones Debbie wyand and
husband Mike lost their son Michael in a
motorcycle accident 12 years ago
and for years have had a memorial cross
set up in his honor at the crash site
until a couple weeks ago when they
noticed it was gone we've had this cross
in in memory of our son Michael
for since 2011.
and
to pass by it and see that it's gone
we just wanted to reach out the Wayans
wondering if the city took it down or
maybe the neighborhood HOA but both have
confirmed that it wasn't them we were
grasping for straws to see if there was
any cameras or security footage and
there was really nothing it was
Michael's wife who told them his cross
was missing after driving by one day
Michael who would have been 33 now is
described by his family as an outgoing
person who loved to explore the outdoors
he loved rock climbing he pretty much
lived at Red Rock but now with his cross
gone his family searching for answers
and having to relive a moment in time
that changed their lives forever we
don't really like to be here because it
reminds us of the accident it just
brings up a lot of sadness again